okay here we are on overtime ice cube
our streaming services like Spotify
unfair to artists um if they don't pay
them right don't pay em do then you
don't have much from front of hood then
I get paid you know No
so Marley a lot I mean most artists
complain about this pennies you know I
mean it's not a lot but you know the
industry has been you know stealing from
artists for a long time so I don't even
know if they know the difference because
you know the industry is just bad you
gotta fight for your money so there's
just another different way of doing yeah
okay Michael eructation how would you
begin to address prison reform in this
country well first of all you'd have to
take the cash out of it private industry
the way in which unfortunately you know
Attorney General session has reignited
that firestorm that had been tamped down
on by Eric Holder so first of all take
the big business out of it and then
secondly have common-sense reform that
was forging a connection between
Democrats and Republicans like what was
going on under Obama before the rise of
sessions in Trump you know Rand Paul is
working right alongside of a Democratic
senator to try to make things work
that's number two number three I think
if we provide people something basic
like opportunities has been shown that
most people who are in prison not the
hardened criminals the nonviolent drug
offenders if they don't have the book
thrown at them they have the opportunity
to make something of their lives look at
the opioid response right now mostly
middle class or even working-class white
brothers and sisters who deserve to get
a second shot but when the crack economy
was going hard in the late 80s there was
no such sympathy if we could have that
model prevail right now I think the
criminal justice reform would be hugely
benefited okay
david jolly what or who is the biggest
obstacle to getting your stop Act passed
look you're not in Congress anymore what
laughing and he's not definitely set up
a bill from getting no but listen this
is important because you know what takes
me off about Donald Trump I spent the
last three to four years in Congress
fighting to rebrand the Republican Party
to accept climate change and marriage
equality and gun control and campaign
finance reform right and and this
president set up back twenty years right
but the stop act is a very simple
measure as four pages it says prohibit
any member of Congress and directly
asking you for money we do it in states
across the country we apply to our
judicial candidates the problem is the
biggest the biggest impediment is big
money drives reelection and listen the
number of members of Congress who came
up to me and said good for you I wish I
could support you but I can't because I
got to go raise a million dollars for
elected that's the biggest room okay
Simone do you think anti-trump sentiment
will carry Democrats in historically red
districts like John Asif and George's
six now absolutely not if you look at
that if you look at that race actually
they're running it on health care and
other issues down there they're not
necessarily running against Donald Trump
Devils have won that district by one
percentage point so it's it's
notoriously close so I think Democrats
will need to talk less about how bad
Republicans are and more about what
they're going to do and what their plans
are and how they different policies to
win in 2018
elected and unenforceable approval
rating people already didn't like them
but they voted him for president anyway
and a lot of Republicans around the
country so it's also want to win they
got to do more than just say all these
people are really bad vote for me that's
a tell them why okay
David Gregory do news journals have a
duty to protect sources that leak
sensitive information from the
government yes I think you should
protect sources I think you know I think
leakers like Jim Comey but but people
who leak in the government are often
doing so to try to influence an outcome
to to reveal something that is that gets
to wrongdoing in the government and I
think it's part of a free press that we
get as much information as we can the
government is built and designed in a
way to only tell the American people
what they want them to know and you have
to have investigative journalists
digging and a lot of times that means
you've got to talk to people anonymously
you got to protect the people who talk
to you to find out what's really going
on yeah I mean reality winner hero
connects MIT can I ask a rap question
without the other one oh please it's
like you know I mean I don't get to hang
out without line dance oh I'm sorry yeah
you know what I'll do I'm going to hang
out with icecube all doctor how do you
compare the rap of your day the flow the
lyrics compared to some of the stuff
today you know you hear future me goes
you know some of these guys how do you
how do you compare it strikes me that
lyrics in your day which is my day we're
a lot more in-your-face a lot more
direct now it's a lot more about flow
and beaten so that's what you think of
it well I think you know rat had a
political edge to it you know it was you
know talking about you know uh you know
doing great things in the community
pushing the program and then at a
certain certain point I think mainstream
media really decided yo you know let's
not promote Public Enemy and K rs1 and
ice-t and Ice Cube because
is what they're saying is look you know
real incendiary you know I'm saying so
let's deal with you know escapism right
let's deal with partying and clubs and
cars and jewelry and money in and that
became the norm and that you know if the
kids see that they're going to emulate
that
so that's became but you know what we've
been kind of feeding off of for the last
twenty years but you know with Kendrick
Lamar you know even even you know Kanye
was one of the first you know jesus
walks with soul you know outside the box
and it was bringing it back to you know
saying something in the rhymes and it
wasn't just escapism doctor that we were
listening to Playboy Carty in the
greenroom
so that's a very don't know lies oh oh
you get mad like micro-irrigation is
Jeff Sessions threatening to restart the
war on drugs
he's already restarted it yeah there's
no doubt about it thinking about pie
will this affect the after party it
depends on what kind of access you have
built oh but you know I got something
[Laughter]
you could do all this on telling me yeah
well range the cords that get money for
Wars became feed the poor I mean yeah
the war on the war on the war on drugs
has been restarted from Nixon Reagan and
now down to sessions and Trump and its
it didn't work the first time around and
put a whole bunch of people in jail who
don't deserve to be there and this time
around I don't think they're going to be
able to keep from putting in a lot of
people who go to free Donald Trump as
well I mean one of the things the point
you were brilliantly making his bill is
that the very people who voted for
Donald Trump are the ones who are being
deserved by him in such legal ways yes
all right thank you for my wonderful
title terrific audience I appreciate
[Applause]